você já parou para pensar na importância
que as escolhas têm na sua vida
o pesquisador publicou em 2015 um estudo
onde afirma que o ser humano faz 35 mil
escolhas todos os dias o que são essas
escolhas na hora que você vai acordar
com que pega você vai pisar fora da cama
que você vai comer um café da manhã no
almoço na janta como você vai ver o seu
trabalho
se você vai dizer bom dia se você vai
sorrir você não vai sorrir
enfim são 35 mil escolhas que a gente
tem a chance de fazer todos os dias em
nossa vida e é sobre essas escolhas que
eu quero falar hoje escolhas que me
trouxeram place tapete que eu tô falando
com vocês
meu nome é guillermo casagrande eu tenho
25 anos e de maneira geral eu posso
dizer que minha vida sempre foi muito
parecida com a de qualquer outra pessoa
com exceção de dois motivos o primeiro é
que meus pais sempre trabalharam muito e
por isso eles não foram tão presente da
minha infância esteve dois lados um lado
ruim é que de fato não é legal você não
tem os seus pais junto com você durante
esse período de desenvolvimento
mas o segundo é o desenvolvimento da
responsabilidade
logo quando você é jovem ea segunda
coisa é você ser deficiente físico ea
sociedade não está preparada para
conviver com você e com as suas
limitações
sim eu tenho uma lesão no lado esquerdo
do meu cérebro que acabou afetando todo
o lado direito do meu corpo então eu
tenho menos mobilidade na minha mão e no
braço um pouco mais fino
minhas pernas também tem uma diferença
meus pés no local os 42 outro aos 41
então um calçado fica muito apertado
fica sobrando um pouquinho é sempre uma
novela né
mas quando eu falo é da sociedade não
sabe lidar com você e com as suas
limitações
eu quero me reportar a um lugar em
específico à escola quando era criança
eu estava dentro da escola a escola
sempre foi um lugar é que eu sofri muito
naquela época se falava de bullying né
se falava de seu lado as pessoas num
porque era diferente é diferente repele
então nem culpa as crianças naquele
momento eu também era criança também
seria naquele ambiente
mas tudo é diferente causa
distanciamento e as crianças de alguma
forma e distanciava principalmente nas
aulas de educação física
eu não tinha habilidade pelo tipo de
esporte é o meu problema era muito maior
do que ele é hoje então perdi o
equilíbrio com alguma frequência quando
o rio é uma trophy avaí ficava aqui no
meu peito e por muitas vezes eu era
motivo de briga entre os times que
estavam sendo montados na educação
física porque ninguém queria ficar
comigo então eu queria fugir de educação
física não queria participar da aula
porque foi um saco eu não queria me
submeter
naquela ocasião naquele momento porque
sabia que de alguma forma eu ia sofrer
um tipo de humilhação mas uma história
que eu quero falar agora ela de 2005
2005 eu e minha irmã ganhamos nossos
pais uma mesa de pingue pongue
e a gente começou a jogar pingue pongue
e todo dia porque a gente era criança e
é muito legal jogar pingue pongue e de
alguma forma acabei desenvolvendo uma
habilidade no esporte pois bem em 2006
a gente mudou de bairro a gente morava
numa ponta da cidade e foi literalmente
mudar na outra ponta da cidade e eu fui
estudar uma nova escola e nessa nova
escola tinha uma mesa de pingue pongue
lembrou né
agora vou inserir nesse ambiente e vou
jogar e vai ser tudo muito legal
enfim igreja tomei coragem entrei na
fila e tinha um cara dentro da escola
que era tipo neymar do pânico embora não
sei se animar uma boa importante né mas
enfim chegou a animar doping de bom e
falei cara vou jogar e aí ninguém
ganhava do cara
chegou minha vez e eu consiga ganhar do
cara de 3 a 0
e naquele momento foi muito mais feliz
mais adiante na minha vida
pena que durou apenas 2 segundos porque
logo para perder dinheiro falou o
seguinte pedir pra qualquer um tudo bem
mas pediu por aleijadinho e cara essa
frase mexeu muito comigo meus pais
lembram mas eu fui pra casa e eu falei
cara eu vi isso hoje não foi legal foi
muito ruim ou péssimo
eu não quero passar por isso de novo não
quero mais que a nossa escola não quero
mais nada e é isso aí eu tive uma das
conversas que foi que foram uma das mais
importantes na minha vida com os meus
pais eles farão cara é o seguinte você
tem essa limitação você tem que entender
que tem essa limitação
mas quem vai decidir o que você vai
fazer com a sua vida daqui para frente é
você e aí eu fiz a primeira grande
escolha da minha vida eu escolhi
entender e aceitar a minha condição
física
daí em diante não tem mais bola sabia
que tinha essa limitação é algumas
coisas até hoje não consigo fazer com
muita facilidade mas eu entendi foi cara
essa minha vida é a condição que eu vim
para este domingo eu vou aceitar e viver
com essa condição que me foi dada
e ainda continuou me tornei adolescente
sempre muito participativo no ambiente
escolar ambiente escolar começou a se
tornar um pouquinho mais legal na minha
vida
e aí eu cheguei no final do ensino médio
e aquele momento consegue fazer mais uma
escolha o que vai ser da minha vida
profissional o que eu vou fazer com a
minha vida
e aí eu tinha 17 anos na época e é a
única coisa que eu tinha certeza é que
eu não queria continuar trabalhando no
emprego os meus pais eu não queria
trabalhar na empresa eles são
empresários eles têm uma rede de lojas
aqui outro ali e eu pensei poxa eu não
quero isso pra mim é por um lado beleza
no desenvolvimento nem maduro mas por
outro lado muito legal
então eu vou estudar publicidade e
propaganda quer que eu achava que sabia
fazer e nós apoiar o cara vai lá vai se
dar publicidade e propaganda muito legal
a gente vai dar uma condição o curso não
tinha pe e um sul que tive que mudar a
figurar no litoral de santa catarina e
eles me impuseram uma condição
você tem que arrumar um emprego a partir
do momento que você arruma um emprego
você vai poder fazer sua faculdade
pois bem 2 de janeiro lá estava eu
fazendo uma entrevista de emprego e foi
aprovado para trabalhar como auxiliar
administrativo uma rede de lojas de
cosméticos entende alguma coisa de
cosmético nada entende alguma coisa de
administração também não mas enfim era o
que tinha que fazer e aí eu comecei a
trabalhar naquele emprego eu fui me
desenvolvendo e curtindo muito aquele
emprego e esse emprego pelo fato de eu
não conhecer muito sobre administração
foi um momento de conexão com os meus
pais porque quando encontrava com eles
eu aproveitava para tirar dúvidas e
perguntar quais as coisas que eu poderia
fazer para tornar o ambiente de trabalho
um pouco melhor com seis meses o
primeiro semestre estava finalizando
primeiro semestre da faculdade e que
estava nesse emprego eu vi que as coisas
estavam erradas
eu estava gostando muito mais do meu
emprego do que do meu da minha faculdade
alencar tem que tomar uma outra escolha
e aí eu fiz uma segunda grande coisa na
minha vida eu escolhi o curso
administração
então eu voltei para o rio sul eu
comecei a trabalhar efetivamente na
empresa os meus pais e comecei a cursar
administração e cara foi muito legal
nesse meio tempo é eu comecei a gostar
muito daquilo que estava estudando e
comecei a trazer alguns resultados
bacanas pra dentro da empresa dos pais
também a gente teve a oportunidade de
desenvolver negócios na china então tive
a oportunidade para a china para a china
algumas vezes e isso foi bem bacana né
eu desenvolvi muito como profissional
e ainda fui seguindo as coisas foram
acontecendo eu estava chegando no fim da
minha faculdade mas eu estava aquela
sensação falei caramba que vai ser a
minha vida que eu falei agora eu fiz a
seguinte decisão estava em dúvida entre
fazer é uma pós-graduação especialização
em neuromarketing ou gestão de pessoas e
aí fui trocar uma idéia com uma
professora que eu tinha com uma mentora
pra mim ela falou o seguinte guilherme
faça uma estrada
você tem perfil do professor e acho que
vai se apaixonar por isso eu falei cara
da mulher não sabe da metade da menina à
escola e que era um lugar que nunca foi
tão legal pra mim o ac milan eo
professor mas enfim de alguma forma que
ele foi correndo na minha mente e quando
eu estava participando de três processos
seletivos de mestrado
tive a honra de ser selecionado em dois
e pode escolher fazer mestrado na
unisinos em porto alegre que foi um
momento muito bacana na minha vida
é um tempo que eu estava no meio do
programa de mestrado foi convidado para
me tornar professor
e aí eu me tornei professor do curso de
jovem aprendiz e eu amei estar em sala
de aula do outro lado está transformando
a vida das pessoas naquela posição e
logo em seguida fui convidado para me
tornar professor universitário então com
23 anos
eu me tornei professor universitário e
eu entendi que aquele lugar era um lugar
que eu queria estar no lugar que fazia
sentido na minha vida pois bem vou falar
um pouquinho eu já falei um pouquinho de
mim na minha vida é profissional mas eu
também tenho algumas operações em uma
meta de vida
eu não sei se vocês já pararam para
pensar até com quantos anos vocês vão me
ver mas eu acredito muito que vou viver
até os 100 anos e eu me propus a cada 25
anos a cada quarta da minha vida e viver
uma experiência muito louca
pois bem ano passado estava com 24
chegou a hora de começar a planejar o
que eu faria quando chegássemos 25 ea
idéia é justamente era fazer um mochilão
de volta ao mundo
eu estava pronto pra ficar um ano
viajando por países subdesenvolvidos a
minha meta ensinar as crianças a falar
em inglês e eu realmente planejei
basicamente tudo que vocês podem
imaginar um filão desde comprar o
equipamento eu queria levar na viagem é
até a documentação por exemplo deixar
uma procuração para a família caso
aconteça alguma coisa eles resolverem
amparada por aqui então isso dá trabalho
pra caramba acreditem pois bem outubro
de 2018
tranquilão
rolando o vídeo no facebook trocando
aids e tudo mais
e encontrei a seguinte manchete ama
viajar e é apaixonado pela educação
temos a vaga do emprego dos sonhos pra
você fizer um emprego pra mim vou
participar desse processo seletivo
pois bem eu e mais sete mil pessoas
resolveram participar desse processo
seletivo de 7.000 a gente caiu para 2500
pessoas de duas mil e 500 mil para 606
em a gente caiu para 200 de 200 agentes
caiu para 17 17 a gente caiu para cinco
finalistas
e aí aconteceu
[Música]
o mundo
i
i oi gente
eu treinei um pouco mais que um tremendo
até agora depois desse ataque epilético
é eu descobri que tinha sido selecionado
para viver o emprego dos sonhos de uma
das empresas que é um dos maiores
bilhões de crédito do mundo né eu estou
tendo a oportunidade agora eu estou em
exercício e está viajando por todo o
brasil com uma missão de levar educação
financeira então eu me conecto com
professores alunos consumidores e eu
mostro a importância de se falar em
educação financeira em um país onde a
gente tem hoje mais de 63 milhões de
pessoas que estão endividadas
então fui selecionado faz parte de um
projeto itinerante que viaja por todo o
brasil e cada semana eu estou num lugar
diferente
já passei por sete estados têm mais
alguns estados há pela frente
está sendo uma experiência muito
incrível de conhecer muita gente me
conectar com muita gente descer e quadro
deixar o meu ego com as outras pessoas
onde eu quero chegar com todo esse
raciocínio é que eu poderia ter seguido
o caminho que a vida preparou pra mim eu
poderia ter escolhido continuar nos
negócios meus pais que vai muito bem
obrigado
eu poderia ter escolhido me colocar numa
posição de vítima pelo fato de ser
deficiente físico e até aproveitar
algumas vantagens que eu tenho por
legislação e por uma série de coisas pra
enfim seguir a minha vida mas eu fiz
escolhas é pra vocês terem noção um dos
maiores sonhos da minha vida era tocar
violão máscara como uma pessoa que tem
apenas uma mão e funciona mesmo é tocar
violão
pois é eu encontrei um cara brasileiro
de petrolina que desenvolveu um violão
que pode ser tocado com apenas uma mão e
eu consegui tocar violão eu toco violão
com uma mão só e saiu sozinho bacana é o
esporte que sempre foi um problema
sempre foi algo e causou tanto
constrangimento que foi algo ruim na
minha vida eu consigo esperar e hoje
participa de provas de rua inclusive
hoje vim aqui na cidade eu participei de
uma prova de corrida ea corrida me
trouxe coisas muito boas
eu comecei a confiar em mim eu conheci
pessoas são incríveis e que hoje fazem
parte da minha vida e não vem em um
momento muito bom
é as escolhas que a gente faz e como o
de maneira ensurdecedora na nossa vida e
na vida das pessoas que estão ao nosso
redor
todos os dias a gente tem 35 mil
escolhas ea gente vai decidir se a gente
vai fazer o bem ao fazer o mal
às vezes podem dar certo e às vezes pode
dar errado
a gente só não pode é ter medo com isso
eu queria fazer um último questionamento
pra vocês
quanto às escolhas você já deixou de
fazer por medo de errar e talvez tenha
deixado de viver coisas incríveis na sua
vida
obrigada
[Aplausos]